you need to target customers who can pay
you otherwise you could be doing a lot
of great work but you're not gonna be
able to pay your bills and you're gonna
have to go back and get a job
hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today Manson a question from a
newsletter reader edith who wrote in to
say thank you so much for the advice you
keep giving me it's really been
invaluable at some point you encourage
me to do something that i really liked
so i started a daycare because my heart
was so much into it it's a long email so
i'll just kind of cut it short first
time i had four kids this is the second
time i fifteen kids the only constraint
is that the mothers are finding it hard
to pay how do I overcome the challenge
of non paying mothers they're poor yet
needy so thanks for the question Edie
and hey congrats I'm excited that my
advice was able to help you launch a
business do something you're passionate
about and build it from four students
are read up to 15 and hopefully a lot
more beyond here's the thing though
here's the truth you have to target
people who can afford to pay you having
four kids to fifteen is great numbers is
great growth hopeful it's a lot bigger
as you keep going but it doesn't mean
anything if the people aren't paying
that's actually costing you money you're
losing money on these people because you
have to feed them you don't have staff
have a location that all costs money you
have to go after mothers who can afford
your service and if they can't then
maybe heartbreaking but you also have a
business to run
it's important to be nice to people and
to want to help I can feel that in your
email it sounds like you really want to
help these people and that's great
that's the foundation of a successful
business but if if you just give
everything away you won't be in business
very long you won't be able to help even
more people you have to get paid and
that comes from targeting customers who
can afford to pay you if you give too
much away to the wrong clients you're
not gonna be able to build your business
you're gonna have to close your doors
you're gonna run out of money if you
really want to support these needy
families which is a great goal have a
scholarship I have a bursary program
will you give one or two spots away per
semester
that people can apply for where it's
free you're at a really discounted rate
and so you can see which which mothers
you really want to help out you can hear
their stories and you can still feel
like you're helping people helping the
needy people who can't necessarily
afford you but otherwise the rest of the
people they have to pay if they don't
pay you don't eat right like it's
critical they have to pay you for what
you do it'll help you build a bigger
business and have a bigger impact and
help more people it's so common that
entrepreneurs undercut their prices give
things away for free do too much work
for free because they love the work they
feel guilty they love the clients but if
you don't get paid one you may have to
close down your business go get a job
and two you won't be able to have a
bigger impact it's great to help three
people or five people or 14 because
you're volunteering your time but if you
want to help hundreds thousands millions
you have to figure out how to get paid I
face a similar challenge as
entrepreneurs I have a weak spot for
entrepreneurs I love helping
entrepreneurs I wake up every day and
and I want to help entrepreneurs most of
the time I don't get paid because
entrepreneurs can't afford my services
why am I making this video because Edith
I want to help you and I want to help
all the other people have the same
problem as you as far as I know I'm not
getting paid for this if there's a check
on the other end let me know but I do it
because I love doing it but I still have
to find a way to get paid I've built up
my business to the point where I can
afford to give back on an ongoing
repeated basis make videos like this
help entrepreneurs one-on-one on videos
online in person I do a lot of work
helping entrepreneurs but they don't
have money I do it because I want to
help them I do because it helps my brand
I guess but mostly because I feel good
doing it I get energy doing it I feel
passionate doing it I would do this even
if I wasn't getting paid which is the
case most of the time but you have to
figure out a way to get paid if you're
doing this as a business you have to
make money bottom line and maybe it's a
scholarship a bursary program for a few
people who can apply and you see
feel good about it but the other people
have to pay you and it may mean firing
your clients and going after better ones
and that's an evolution a lot of
entrepreneurs go through they start the
business taking any any clients they can
just to bring money in but as you grow
you work with bigger clients well good
people can afford you more people who
value your service more and will pay you
for it
and you often have to fire your other
clients as a result the ones who aren't
paying the one who don't respect you as
much the ones who aren't you know trust
in the value that you're bringing and
are willing to pay you for good luck go
get paid go get the right clients if
those are you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes me want to do more for you and
I want to hear from you please leave a
comment under the video about this video
or something about your own business a
question you have that I can answer for
you I really read every comment that
comes in trust me and I try to respond
everybody personally so I look forward
to hearing from you
thank you guys and I'll see you soon